this is national black business month
it's a chance to showcase the successes
and the challenges of getting a dream
off the ground Mary Jane beliesza
profiles one local black business owner
who's helped stretches Beyond the Valley
Hassan tespa loves making people look
and feel good he is The Man Behind CMOS
products it's a really good
anti-inflammatory so it breaks up
inflammation within the bodies what's
great for stiff joints inflammation the
lungs but getting his new company to
scale was a challenge Tesla got help
from another black owned company Global
Soco they've allowed me to Branch out
into different markets to step into the
digital space they set me up with a
website so I could reach more people
Moses kusasera is the CEO of global Soco
he helps young entrepreneurs sell their
products online individuals don't even
know each other but now they're
collaborate collaborating and selling
together M.A KUSI says this platform
gives business owners recognition it's a
new way to compete in the marketplace
the challenges we're having is creating
websites because um nowadays the
e-commerce business and the whole
pandemic we have to kind of brainstorm
and think outside the box Kusa Sarah
says celebrating black owned businesses
this month is a great way to show
appreciation and give a helping hand and
the idea is that we have to basically
include everybody you know from the
normal mom and pop all the way to the
big big Brands this month is black
business month anybody can participate
Mary Jane valleza 8 News Now